turning to tennis been waiting all
morning for this teenage phenom is cory
coco Gough you've heard of her it's
focusing on her future of her world when
run at Wimbledon this 15 year old tennis
player captivated the world after
defeating one of her idols Venus
Williams in the very first round you go
golf became the youngest player since
1991 to reach round 4 at Wimbledon she
lost yesterday that's okay to former
world number 1 Simona Halep Coco Golf
joins us from Wimbledon England right
now good morning and congratulations on
playing a great tournament thank you so
much can I just say that I am Coco nuts
for you you know I don't know whether to
call you Cinderella but as far as I'm
concerned you're still Cinderella
wearing the glass slipper but this is
what I want to know Coco yeah how you
were able to play the way you played and
the pressure you must have felt so I'm
wondering did you feel the pressure and
what's your strategy on dealing with
pressure yeah um I didn't feel I
definitely felt pressure I didn't feel
so nervous and my strategy was just like
whatever happens happens and I believe
everything happens for a reason
so I kind of just like said let me just
enjoy the moment because there's not not
too many people in the world get to
experience this so I just kind of went
out there in the mindset of just
enjoying it and let's see what I can do
I know but set it up for us because I
it's my understanding the night before
you were taking a test and then the next
day you're heading to England to play in
the qualifying rounds and then you go on
from there yeah yeah it was crazy like
life literally changed in seconds I got
the call that we got the wild card and
we literally booked the play and I
believe that night left and then went
him went to took play qualies and then I
ended up winning and well he went my way
through that and then I found out I got
to play Venus Williams in the first
round that was crazy because I always
dreamed in the moment you know you kind
of you kind of don't expect it so Coco
how do you approach playing one of your
idols in the opening round at Wimbledon
I was just trying to play her like a
normal like I would play somebody else
um
when during the match I kind of did not
think about it oh I'm playing Venus
but as soon as mash point was over I
literally was like I can't believe like
that just happened and I still can't
believe it as well so you're not going
oh that's Venus on the other side of the
court yeah I tried my best not to think
about it as much as possible so this is
life-changing for you right now I guess
I've got two questions one are you gonna
have to keep taking exams before matches
right and two how will your tailor your
training in your preparation change if
at all I mean I guess if it's working
don't get don't change it um yeah one to
answer your first question basically
until I graduated college I guess I've
gotta have to take exams during my
tournaments and then to answer the
second one I feel like my training will
remain the same obviously we work on new
things like cuz my dad likes to look at
tournaments as a test and then to see
what we can improve on and then then we
go back to practice and see what we
improve on but pretty much my training
will remain the same just maybe what we
work one will be different
Coco I'm so smitten with your family I
loved watching you but your dad is Cory
he's in the stands your mom candy yes I
love watching them you've got a brother
Cody 11 and Cameron six so clearly I see
names all work in that family so did you
ever take content did you did you have
anything where you made contact with
your parents when you're on the court
how did that work for you yeah so
actually in the match I try not to look
at my parents too much but definitely
when I have a big come on or ice cream I
look at them because they kind of hyped
me up and then sometimes when I feel a
little bit tight in the match I kind of
look at them because they just give me
fist pumps so that just kind of shows me
that everything's gonna be okay you're
my biggest supporters your mom's got
dance move I know yes I saw the videos
of her actually during the match I
didn't see I probably would have bursted
out laughing but um I saw heard her
dance moves and maybe we should take her
to work on those so a lot of people have
reached out to you you know Snoop Dogg a
lot of people have tweeted what has
stood out for you who've you heard from
cuz I think this is very cool - yeah
definitely
um speaking to miss Michelle Oh or
seeing Miss Michelle Obama tweeted
do you mean that was crazy she's
definitely been a role model I mean the
way she handled herself throughout the
whole of Barack Obama's term it was
amazing and she just continues to fight
for girls and everything and that was
definitely really exciting and also
Jaden Smith him tweeting me um I kind of
had the biggest crush on him when I was
younger so him tweeting me was crazy and
all my friends were freaking out because
they know how much I liked him I mean I
I don't know I and his album is amazing
I like his music but yeah it was
definitely crazy Coco we think you were
just getting started something tells me
you're gonna meet Michelle Obama before
this is all over I have a feeling that
is gonna have he'll be crazy insane you
may only be 50 but we think you're a
role model already - yes Oh God thank
you so much for being with me can't wait
to see you when you came to me this is
an invitation yes I'm so excited see yes
okay thank you thanks for taking the
time today all right Coco go thanks
again for having me